and huge product giveaways game on
game on indeed thank you bob and welcome
everyone to razer store live ces 2021
edition
my name is latigras and i am joined by
bravo i haven't seen you since we were
here the last time how you been i know
just gonna say last time we're here at
the razer store in las vegas was razer
con 2020 and it's great to be back here
of course not only with you but also
with the entire razer community now this
is going to be
razer store live number three this is
the third episode in the series but it's
a very special edition
it is the ces edition yeah we are so
honored to be a part of this now monthly
reoccurring show but we are also the
lucky ones that have gotten to be here
for special editions whether it was
razercon
or now here with ces which is operating
a bit differently this year taking place
between january 11th
and 14th it is the first time it is
completely digital and bravo i know
you've had experience with this trade
show in the past i have yeah i've been
coming to ces for years now maybe 10
years and back then you know gaming was
a very small part of ces
compared to how it is now and it's no
surprise that at a show like this
that razer's going to come out with all
the stops today so i'm really excited
about today's show but we should let
everyone know a little bit about us
i mean you have been very busy and you
also have a very busy lcs year coming up
as well
ah yeah if you uh know me it's likely
from the league of legends and that's
where i spend most of my time this is a
big
week for gaming and esports whether it
be ces or we're kicking off lcs at the
end of the week
and bravo for anyone that isn't as
familiar with you or didn't get to meet
you last time around how did you get
into gaming and what you've been up to
i'm just a guy who played a lot of games
and somehow convinced people to work on
a pro i worked on the halo franchise for
a while and now cast games like apex
legends and lucky to do shows like this
with you and uh
yeah excited to be here but like we said
we're jumping into ces week and it's
time to get excited for today's show
yeah this is a trade show that is all
about presentations
in technology and innovation for the
future after all so it makes sense that
razer
is always ready to come with some sort
of surprise
of course it wouldn't be a razor show if
we didn't have something extra special
in store for you all
we'll be having our giveaways throughout
the day if you haven't signed up for
that already you can do so at razer.com
slash razor store slash live and in
addition to that you can also share your
battle stations with us on instagram all
you gotta do is tag
razer or use razer ces 2021 as well
and i know we'll be looking at those
throughout the broadcast today
absolutely we know that so many of you
guys whatever channel and whatever
platforms you're watching on we're going
to keep be keeping an eye on chat we
know so many of you are excited for
those giveaways we got plenty of those
coming up and also
don't want to spoil it just yet but we
will have a special guest in today's
show as well
yes special guests new products
partnership
announcement so much to look forward to
but before we look towards the future
we have to look back at 2020 a
magnificent year for razer and to help
us do that
we're bringing in our buddy it is the
store manager here at razer store las
vegas we have andy schaefer
come on down join us at our little
bungalow hey what's up man great to be
back here at the store yeah
great to be joining you again 2020 of
course a challenging year in many ways
but we have to also say for razer an
exciting year in terms of some some
hardware that we got to see oh yeah most
definitely you know we'll just kick it
off with
our favorite 60 keyboard the huntsman
mini so
we've got here the mercury white color i
know you love your clicks but i brought
you that purple clicky switch i'm going
to say we got
the clickiest of switches here with the
purple switches and i love this thing
in terms of a small form factor
hopefully we'll see a few in some battle
stations but
uh yeah a big huntsman mini fan myself
yeah very much in line with
i mean just the trend in trying to be as
efficient with your space as possible 60
keyboards in this one being so beautiful
to see i know the last time
we were in here we had the pleasure of
getting to see
the esker chair there was only one
though and i was having to battle it out
to try and get a seat in that thing
yeah so yeah so a foray to you know new
area for us and really that lumbar
support the modular armrests everything
about that just really keeping that
lifestyle and
keeping razor on the forefront of
everything what's good now too is we
were we were here so like
the escrow you had might even have a
production sample we had early iskers
but now we've actually got a few in the
store gabby i don't have to fight
anymore
all as well we're now making friendships
instead of
breaking them apart but i'm also
convinced that one of the only reasons
that we're still friends is because we
haven't actually played console games
together and i know that's why you're
extra excited to talk about the next few
things that we got to learn about when
it comes to 2020.
yeah so the cairo pro super exciting new
headset for the new generation of
console
xbox wireless connection also comes with
bluetooth so you can go with mobile or
you can go with pc
and then you know just because we keep
talking about those clickies the
wolverine v2
so super exciting new generation of
controller yeah i mean i've been a fan
of the razer controllers for a long time
especially if you think think about the
wolverine v2
all the way back to the sabertooth
mechanical ax by i think people who have
grown to love
uh clicky switches and a lot of haptic
feedback on their keyboards maybe they
grew up on console they then they moved
to play
games like starcraft dota league and
they got used to mechanical keyboards
if you haven't tried a mechanical ax by
buttons on your controller you've got to
try it out if you play on controller all
it really is great in the wolverine v2
for sure yeah i mean
that just showing how far advancement
can come kind of in allowing you to
raise your skill level as you're in the
console gaming space i personally love
the bluetooth compatibility as well as
when you're bringing things through but
another thing is where i'm excited to
get my hands on it was actually a year
ago
that we ended up first learning about
this product here at ces
it's the kishi really elevating the
mobile gaming experience yeah so
uh like you said last year kishi best of
ces award winner
brought one over here for you don't
break my phone um but you know it's
it's definitely a game changer in
multiple ways so you've got not just
you know the ability to play games
completely different but just
bringing a whole new level of gameplay
to mobile
yeah this is definitely what i'm going
to be keeping my hands on
so much in march when wild rift drops
it's already perfect with the dual
thumbsticks and everything
so i'm definitely going to be looking at
this one
in the future but there's another aspect
that we have to touch on because
when it comes to last year the razer
book 13 ended up making such a splash
yeah most definitely so just you know
taking as bob said it you know just the
overpowering of all of our systems all
into one into that nice
sleek form factor the the thin bezels
all the way around per key rgb
vapor cooling chamber everything you
could possibly want a nice slim
productivity laptop you've got it
yeah absolutely and people were so
excited we were keeping an eye on chat
last time just how excited they were
about the tomahawk
we'll maybe be uh featuring those and
some giveaways later today we'll have to
see
oh yeah i mean the tomahawk was
something that was a big talking point
but i think just when you're thinking
about the desktop experience in general
it's huge
yeah so the tomahawk gaming desktop once
again last year at ces
and now we've got it full out so rtx 30
series cards we've got that full
powerful desktop
everything you expect from a razer in a
nice compact portable system
now the fact that we even have these
razer store
live events are showcasing the fact that
we are all
about community bringing that lifestyle
integrating it regularly within your
lives and one way that put this at the
forefront as bob did touch on earlier on
in the video
was this collaboration we have the
partnership with
babe i see you rocking the gear right
now i'm pretty jealous
i'm gonna say you you clearly copped we
did not cop and you have
you have the vape gear we don't but i'm
not gonna lie it's a pretty sweet
partnership yeah it definitely is
great partnership i i feel really lucky
that i was able to get through and you
know get one of the pieces and it's it's
definitely super comfortable and i think
that just that the
once again growing expansion of our
lifestyle products all the way through
from gaming
everywhere is really what this
partnership has done yeah i think we're
going to have a few announcements that
people are pretty excited about today
too in that department but all of that's
still to come of course
yeah and we of course also want to know
what you have to say in the audience
what do you
think about what you see on your screen
right now let us know in chat we are
looking at those regularly
interacting with you all and another
nice thing about having andy here is if
you haven't actually had
an in-store experience this guy's the
expert what kind of things are you doing
here at the store
uh lots of different stuff so you know
as you can see that we we're all wearing
masks we're cleaning our displays all
the time
and just really making sure that that
experience is there so customers can
come in feel safe feel comfortable
and get that full razor experience no
matter what's going on and you also got
you have some deals
you have some deals that people can
always look forward to of course at
razor store but you've also got
a pretty exciting set of things going on
today but let's talk about first day
store exclusives if people are shopping
at razorstore.com or in razorstore what
they can look forward to why would they
shop here
yeah so next day business shipping at
razorstore.com
allows it come to you really quick
whatever you're looking for 14 day risk
free return policy so that's going to be
both online and in our razer stores
then up to three years warranty with
razor care so you've got that peace of
mind from the start to the end
all the way through absolutely of course
another cool thing is as we mentioned
earlier this is
you're able to do razor store live shows
now from the stores this is the third
episode so we're so glad you guys
are joining for this one but on top of
that in the razer store we've also got
some exclusive products that you only
have here which are pretty exciting too
we do so you know let's start off the
black shark v2 special edition
so we just got stuff hanging out all
over the place so you know one of the
things that's great about this is just
the color way
so that's what makes it the special
edition um razor store exclusive
is that black and green exclusive
colorway you're not going to see that
anywhere else razorstore.com razor
stores themselves
comes with a nice green black hard case
as well and that's just an amazing piece
to kind of add that style
when you're trying to really enhance
your audio experience i do want to touch
on the mice that we have because i know
last time we were here this one in
particular the cyberpunk 2077
edition was super sonic's favorite i
believe he's watching at home too so
hello
yeah we'll miss you about your you have
one at home mouse
so never mind we have oh yeah all right
he's covered then he's covered
but i mean the great thing about
something like this right is you already
get that functionality that we know and
love with the razer product but then you
get that extra level of style
right yeah so the viper ultimate that
ultra lightweight mouse that we've got
the wireless everything all in there and
then that cyberpunk
just exclusive styling that you'll only
find um through razer yeah i gotta say
the first
the one thing about these two
specifically is the weight of this
headset here the black shark v2 as well
as the weight of the mouse
we'll blow anyone away i think when you
look at i mean we've all had
gaming headsets over the years from
different manufacturers that we've tried
out
the weight of this headset specifically
i think as you look at people who are
creating content for
much longer durations especially in a
pandemic world where we're all working
from home even longer and you've got a
headset on your
head for hours a day whether you're
gaming working creating
uh the weight of the headset blew me
away and that's why i had to get one for
sure
yeah yeah this ain't the only mouse
though no
there's another mountain specially made
for me you know i'll pretend that that
was razer's motivation when they
introduced the razer naga left hand
we got to dig into this right because
we've only andy you and i have only just
learned
like yesterday does gabby started
mentioning oh yeah i use a left-handed
mouse and a right-handed mouse
i'm like what kind of ambidextrous mouse
nonsense is going on here you got one
mmo mouse
what what is that all right look i am a
left-handed individual that grew up in a
right-handed household so i was using a
righty mouse for the longest time
realized that my accuracy is actually
better in fps with my left hand this was
just last year i ended up switching it
for valerians but i couldn't get myself
to switch for
moba play that is still just all right
hand for me
but i prefer having an ergonomic mouse
on both whether i'm using left or right
so my setup literally has the keyboard
and then a right mouse
and a left mouse so this is perfectly
suited for me
you don't see it you're thankful for
oversized mats more than anyone because
you actually have to have
mice on each side i'm also picturing you
with like four arms like you've got
you've got two hands on the keyboard and
then hands on the mice and it's really
freaky i spend most of my holiday
redoing my setup adding the
phillips hue strips and everything to
get my rgb lighting all around
setting up my map properly i'm still
looking actually to replace some of
those
which actually brings me to our next
point because when
i was looking to replace some of my gear
with the razer products
there was a little birdie that told me i
needed to hold off because maybe there's
going to be some kind of special deal
going on
yes so starting today through january
17th
20 off your second item at
razorstore.com or razer stores so
once again those razer stores are here
in las vegas london hong kong
san francisco and taipei so we've got
those five stores so if you're a
lucky one to be able to get or online
yeah that's a ces exclusive
yeah only through january 17th another
one that we uh didn't talk about
to talk about was that blade 15 courts
as well of course being exclusive here
the quartz line i know you've got
friends who have entire court setups
that's how it tends to be if you have a
quartz or a mercury setup
you are all in and i think it's great
because as we're going to probably see
later
the quartz of the mercury setups you can
go you know across the siren line uh
keyboards mice etc you can get great
looking setups for sure oh yeah
i mean that whole corner over there
right over there somewhere
yeah if anybody actually gets a chance
to come down to the store and check it
out if you are a fan
of all the quartz products it's
basically laid out there
for you but andy this is such a
wonderful
recap of everything that we have going
on we'll still talk to you throughout
the show
we'll see you again yeah but i'm taking
this with me you don't need to keep it
okay sorry
we'll see you we took the black shark
v2s with them but that's okay uh but
as you heard the ces sale is now
underway and once again we want to
welcome all of you and who might have
come in after the opening of the show
welcome
to a very special ces edition here at
razer store live this is episode number
three
and we're coming at you with a special
episode that we've been pretty excited
about let us know in chat where you're
tuning in from we know
razer was such a global audience it's
been amazing to see everyone tuning in
from all around the world so let us know
what city what country
what time zone you're tuning in from
because we thank you for all hours of
the day tuning in to watch this episode
of razer store live but i think gabby
that gets us ready to really kick off
the show and move into 2021 yep we took
our reflection
upon 2020 and it is now officially time
to look towards the future it is ces
after all so we're ready to announce our
very
first partnership introducing to you all
upcoming for the first time we have
razer
x sanrio now this is the hello kitty and
friends brand with which many are
familiar
and i'm sure they've probably seen them
in the past of course a beloved brand
that has so many great partnerships i
think
razor as well when you think of a brand
like razer and a fan base like razer
coming together
with something like sanrio now hardcore
razer fans will have seen a little bit
of glimpses
from asia just a few months ago a few of
the products that were starting to come
out there from this partnership but
this announcement here is the global
announcement that these products are
coming to the globe not limited to a
specific region so i think fans of
sanrio and razer and especially the two
are going to be really excited about
this just because of of the brands that
both have built
i'm excited to see what the products are
i saw the tick tocks that came out out
of asia
people were going nuts when they saw how
sweet the mice looked everything looked
uh fantastic so i'm really excited about
this partnership for sure it's always so
cool when you can merge
different passions as you just mentioned
we already know the razer community to
be very thoroughly passionate about the
products and kind of engaging in that
and then obviously
who doesn't love hello kitty i've seen
people so committed that on the highway
i have seen a car completely clad in a
hello kitty design
so i cannot wait to see what you've seen
but entire jumbo jets like eva air
the the all the way uh and asia has
entire
not just hello kitty outfitted aircraft
but when you're on board you get like
hello kitty utensils all this stuff with
your like meals so what i'm getting at
is when you look at
i mean when you look at a brand like
razer when you look at a brand like
sanrio they don't take partnerships and
collaborations lightly they go all in
and i can't wait to see what we get from
them
putting me that much closer to becoming
hello kitty
in my own mind right just fully
embodying
well all of this will be coming to you
in spring of 2021 so make sure you're
sticking around
so that you can figure out exactly what
is coming through but we love
spurring that excitement bravo
absolutely i can't wait to see what we
see from this partnership i know people
who have gotten glimpse of the stuff
that
they already got looks at are really
excited i know we are too
yeah that was just our first partnership
announcement of the day
i think it's time for us to get into a
second one
all right everybody it is ces time so
introducing
to you boulders gate three let's check
it out
the ancient powers have awoken
and they now lie at the tips of your
fingers
allow them to breathe new life into the
moment
as you face a new journey towards
boulder's gate
[Music]
here they can help you make your
decisions
showing you the full weight of your
actions
[Music]
where you can feel their power rise from
the depths
as you press on
their magic coursing through your hands
[Music]
as you defeat everyone that lies before
you
[Music]
come
[Music]
and experience yourself
larian studios the developers and
publishers behind boulder's gate three
coming in hot
here absolutely i think people are
really excited about balder's gate now
when steam early access came out in just
around early october
the community's really excited i think
as a guy who's worked on game
development for a while especially in
community management
it's amazing to see what they're doing
um what they're saying about baldrige g3
is it's ready when it's ready and i
think people have been really excited
about
steam early access so far and the way
that they're approaching the game
development but also
now as you see here going to be excited
about the chroma integration as well
because it looks you could just tell how
intentional it is in terms of really
dialing that in for the full gameplay
experience
and that's going to be coming along just
later this month we talk about how razer
really has this goal of increasing the
level of immersion players feel when
they're engaging in these games
and what better way to do it through the
chroma rgb system
i particularly enjoyed in the video that
i'm talking about letting your actions
be heard and felt and
that's really the level you get when you
integrate in this way yeah it's cool i
think to be honest i think there's going
to be a standard when you look at
even the rates of broadcast having
chroma integration when you look at
things like the razer con 2020
after party having chrome integration i
think there's gonna they it's gonna
continue where people are just expecting
chroma integration in all of their
experiences because they're building
setups that allow them to
to really once again just be totally
immersed into that situation yeah yeah
16.8 million that's the number i'm
throwing out to you that's how many
colors are in the
chroma rgb system so really a whole
level of personalization customization
reaction
to that integration that i know we're
all looking forward to
bravo though i get so excited about
these kind of announcements that just
makes me want to share
the love a bit with the community you
think it's time
i think so all right everyone we're
going to get into some giveaway
territory for those that may have missed
it earlier the way for you to sign up
for these giveaways
is to go to razer.com razorstor
live and you can also share images of
your battle station with us on instagram
tagging razer and using hashtag razer
ces
2021 because we'll be taking a look at
those battle stations throughout the
show
absolutely just like we did at razorcon
you guys might remember and you've seen
in another razer store live shows as
well we want to highlight our favorite
battle stations from instagram
throughout the show so the razer
social team is here they're going to be
picking some of their favorites but
let's go ahead and
talk about what we're going to be giving
away here for this giveaway because
pretty excited about this two things
that we talked about a little bit
earlier
yeah we got the wolverine v2 controller
and the cairo pro
headset you know that we are geeking
over these
early i mean bravo you had them in your
hands you felt how good that feels
so this is something you'll definitely
be wanting to take home but there's only
going to be one
lucky winner of this giveaway and what's
cool too gabby you mentioned about these
when we were talking about them earlier
but
don't think of this as a console
exclusive bundle kyra pro is going to
work not only for xbox as well as pc but
mobile as well
and of course the wolverine v2 maybe
you've moved from console to pc as a lot
as many many people have a lot of the
guys
and girls that i grew up with have moved
from a console to pc background so
even if you go in between the two that
wolverine v2 is going to be great too so
essentially
it's a great bundle for whatever
whatever setups you're running
especially if you have multiple setups
at home
yeah i love being able to just go from
my pc setup to my mobile with the
bluetooth but we also want to
acknowledge the battle stations that
we've been hyping up throughout the
entirety of the broadcast thus far
the first one is coming to you at odin
force gaming
has brought it here i love he's actually
using they're using a lot of colors that
are pretty much in trend right now for
2021 the cool tones if you will
absolutely it's a really nice setup here
from odenfor's gaming thank you so much
for submitting your battle station on
instagram and also
slow silver.se looks like coming in from
sweden with the vertical setup
kind of cool because normally as you
just saw and as we'll see probably for
the rest of the time
often it's horizontal setups multiple
monitors kind of spread across which
is your standard desk setup but i like
this slow silver kind of building a
little bit of a compact setup there
vertically
just because you're using a smaller
amount of safe doesn't mean that you
can't actually stack it up right
and then very much contrasted by our
next submission from brandy gono frieza
a lot more horizontal action even has
the nano leaves in the back
yeah it's a good looking setup too yeah
these were some of the ones that have
been shown off
across instagram but there is only one
winner of this giveaway
and that winner is i'm in from the
united states
congratulations on your prize i am sure
you're going to be thrilled
to hear this but don't worry everybody
we have more giveaways coming including
a rolly berg one at the end
we do have a really big one you guys
might have seen it teased that's a full
peripheral set we'll get to that one
don't worry but i'm in
the razer social team's going to be
reaching out to you so you can claim
your prize congrats on winning and
everyone
once again razer.com live to get your
entries in as well
yeah so we've gotten through a giveaway
we've done a couple partnership
announcements rob are you ready to get
into some hardware i was going to say i
think it's time for hardware i think ces
uh hardware is the the language uh that
we eat sleep and breathe when we get to
an event like ces and i think it's time
to get into it yeah let's get into it
my friends eugene and leon from the
razer team are joining us from the
safety and comfort of their living rooms
let's check it out
hi i'm leon product marketing manager at
razer
and i'm eugene senior marketing manager
for razer north america
today we'll be giving you the lowdown on
our latest and greatest laptop products
at razer we have always taken pride in
crafting the best products for gamers
and content creators
and through the years our laptops have
been critically acclaimed by
world-renowned media
we've received awards and accolades from
some of the top tech reviewers worldwide
such as pc gamer
windows central and tech radar and we're
proud to say that even our newest
products such as the razer book 13
the tomahawk gaming chassis and tomahawk
gaming desktop
and the razer raptor 27 have all been
extremely well received
we make laptops that we personally want
to use and own
that's why our engineers are always
pushing the limits of building products
to the highest possible standards
we use a state-of-the-art cnc milling
process to fabricate a unibody design
ensuring an exceptional build quality we
also integrate things like vapor chamber
cooling solutions to maximize our
thermal capabilities in order to harness
as much performance as possible
but we don't just stop there great user
experience lies at the very core of our
laptops
by not installing unnecessary
applications razer laptops are ready to
go out of the box
this helps our users to maximize storage
space and saves them precious time down
the line
razer synapse and razer chrome rgb help
to solidify
the full feature set of our laptops
allowing you to adjust
performance settings fan curves and
personalize
your lighting for greater immersion so
what do we have in store for you at
cs2021
well we're super excited to announce the
brand new
world's smallest gaming laptop the
blaz15 as well as the ultimate desktop
replacement
blade pro 17 gaming laptops these bad
boys house the next generation
of high performance gpus that will
dominate the future of gaming
and can be fitted with nvidia geforce
rtx 3080 gpus
to maximize your gaming experience so
leon tell me about some of the awesome
new features that you are most excited
about seeing on the new blades well
i'm definitely excited about the new
display panels as these come with even
more configurations um
we basically expanded the entire lineup
and added on
additional features many of you guys are
going to want to get your hands on the
latest qhd
1440p panel which basically go up to
240hz which provide
greater resolution for detail as well as
an extremely fluid movement
these panels will also incorporate
nvidia g-sync technology with advanced
optimus
and this helps to sync your refresh rate
with your graphics card to prevent any
screen tearing
for those of you guys interested in
playing high paced games with lots of
action
we push the limits of our full hd panels
to the extreme
with refresh rates up to 360 hertz this
allows you to get the competitive edge
against your opponent
with even more precision well for
content creators and professionals out
there we still offer our fan favorite 4k
oled touch panels on our highest end
configuration so
you know if you're uh looking to work on
a lot of content
we got you covered we've even expanded
our storage on our blade 15
advanced to include two m.2 ssd slots so
it's gonna allow a lot more flexibility
as well
however one of the most highly
anticipated features of all
is definitely gonna be the nvidia
geforce rtx 30 series graphics
we have a variety of configurations
across many skus from our blade pro 17
to our blade 15 to offer gamers the
latest in graphics technology
performance
from dlss to ray chasing for select
blade 15 models users can choose between
a geforce rtx 3080 gpu with eight gigs
of vram
or even one with 16 gigs of vram this
allows creators to
complete complex tasks and projects
faster than ever before
and here to tell us more about this
technology is our partners from nvidia
we are excited to partner with razer to
bring the new geforce rtx 30 series gpus
to razer blade gaming laptops these new
gpus are based on the award-winning
nvidia ampere architecture
which enables the world's fastest
laptops for gamers
and creators with second generation ray
tracing cores
and third generation tensor cores for ai
features like dlss
you'll get the fastest performance plus
the most realistic and immersive
graphics
in top games and creative apps
our platform includes nvidia reflex
which gives you the lowest latency in
comparative games
when combined with your new razer blade
laptops available in up to 1080p
360hz and 1440p 240hz
gives you a huge competitive advantage
there's also nvidia broadcast which
transforms your live streams and video
conferences with ai enhanced noise
removal
virtual green screen and auto frame
we all need this working from home and
attending school remotely
geforce rtx 30 series laptops feature
the latest max-q technologies for
optimal power and performance
first the acclaimed nvidia dlss uses ai
rendering to provide a massive
performance boost at the same power
level
and it looks as good or even better than
traditional rendering
secondly ai powered dynamic boost 2.0
continuously balances the power across
the cpu
the gpu and even the gpu memory every
frame for maximum performance
while you're gaming and creating next
the re-engineered whisper mode 2.0 takes
your desired acoustic level
and then using ai-powered algorithms
manages the gpu cpu
system temperatures and fan speeds to
deliver the best possible performance
lastly we are adding resizable bar which
is an advanced capability of pci express
that enables the cpu to access the
entire gpu memory
for greater game performance the new
razer laptops with geforce 30 series
graphics provide incredible performance
and new features
while being more compact than ever we're
excited for gamers to get their hands on
them
thanks guys i'm sure you're all excited
to get your hands on the new razer blade
laptops
eugene after talking about the razer
blade pro 17
the razer blade 15 and all the
technologies we're going to be offering
this time around
what are you most excited about well to
be honest
just playing games man these laptops
these blade 15s that blade pro 17s are
going to be able to do so much
with the new nvidia ampere architecture
with the 3080
you're going to see awesome gaming
performance um and the new display
panels are going to be great with
that qhd and 240hz right
and along with that you get g-sync so
you get the best of everything
all packed in a super portable form
factor yeah and definitely with the qhd
panels this is something that we've
gotten
we've developed and integrated into our
platform because of the feedback you
guys have told us
we send a lot of our laptops out and we
work with medias and reviewers
and everyone says that they want
something different something better
they want that higher detail and
definition and resolution
and this is what we have and it's all
thanks for you guys right
um so i think this platform and the
laptop is definitely a product made for
gamers by gamers
yeah well uh leon what about you what
what are you most excited to see
on the new blades well i think there's a
lot of things to come
out of this um we're seeing a lot of
cool innovation i'm excited to see games
running on it
and it's definitely a mobile platform
that you can take around and with
expanded storage this is something that
you no longer have to delete games to
get new games right
that's definitely a plus for everyone
well thank you guys so much for tuning
in
uh for razer at ces 2021 uh
super excited to announce the brand new
blaze to you guys
make sure to keep your eyes peeled for
when these laptops go
on pre-order today all right see you
guys
love getting to hear directly from
eugene and leon the masterminds behind
what you see
before you and i did have to bring in
andy once more because there is so
much to talk about when it comes to this
announcement there really is we got to
talk
start with the blade 15 like you just
saw in the video and anyone who has
multiple tabs open trying to track ces
news might have seen a little bit of
blade 15 reveal from the nvidia stream
as well but
let's talk about this new new and
improved blade 15. yeah
so still the world's best gaming laptop
so with the rtx 30 series cards that we
saw is just
it blows away everything that's out
there it's got the fastest displays
eugene lee and kicked off on all those
different pieces you know with the qhd
screens everything like that
and it's truly the smallest 15-inch
gaming laptop on the market i mean
displays up to 360 hertz on a 15-inch
display is just crazy i mean
it feels like just a few years ago when
we were even just talking about 240 as
the cap
i believe it was last year at ces
announcement yeah last year at ces it
was the
300 hertz and this year 360. you know
what what's going to be next but 360 is
just crazy
absolutely now i'm always so curious
about when things become smaller and
smaller and you're saying this is the
smallest 15-inch laptop and it comes to
the actual kind of profile of it but the
way i think of it is like
hardware you know how do you keep
getting it to perform and get
just into that capacity so i can feel
nice and compact
that's just amazing that they keep
innovating on that yeah without a doubt
you know the fact that you know
bigger and better is slimmer and better
and with all the different ports that
we've got in there
all the powerhouse graphics everything
that you could possibly want
is in this sleek stylish system that
we've had on display the whole show i
was going to actually say we haven't
told people we've been running a
updated blade 15 right here but also you
brought out
which i hope you leave this time you
brought out a blade 17 pro i mean this
is the powerhouse this is your compact
ultra mobile desktop replacement so yes
so
ultra thin ultra fast ultra powerful is
the blade 17 pro
so it is one of it is the most powerful
system that is out there so like you
said the desktop replacement
everything that's out there we've got
the rtx once again 30 series graphics in
there
all the different resolutions are going
to have super fast displays
compact ultra ultra mobile desktop
replacement
as well as a wide selection once again
of ports connectivity everything
everything you could possibly want
is right here absolutely i mean i'm a
guy who i had a blade 13
earlier when the first set of blades
came out uh the blade
stealth that is and it's crazy to now
see just how many options that you heard
lugine and leon talking about in the
video too
just how many options you have across in
terms of display options
in the blade 17 alone it's pretty
amazing and i know you guys probably get
a lot of people in here kind of asking
about
how which exact one of these should i
get and that's going to even continue
because there's so many more options
in the new blade 17. yeah yeah most
definitely there's just you know so many
different
options builds and everything like that
and i know that we were talking about
customization and stuff right yeah
because that's always what i'm curious
about i feel like a lot of gamers come
in and they're thinking all right i want
to customize i want to build something
from
the ground up how often do you get that
as a question
and then just being able to enlighten
them on how many different versions and
things are already
are yeah all the time it's a common
thing here in the stores and you know
one of the greatest things is because we
do have so many different displays
the gpu process the different sizes of
the laptops we're able to truly
customize your experience with
everything that we already have so
although it is a custom it's not a true
custom build
we've got all the different pieces that
you could want we will find the right
system for you
speaking of finding the right system for
anybody who has already decided i found
it i see it on my screen
these are amazing and i want either the
blade 17 pro or the blade 15
can they get access yeah so you know
eugene leon mentioned pre-orders coming
soon how about pre-orders coming today
yeah
so razorstore.com and in your local
razor store whether you're here in las
vegas
london san francisco hong kong or taipei
you'll be able to stop by
or once again razorstore.com we'll get
some pre-orders going for you guys i
know people are excited about them uh
the the
the entire blade line just continues to
be more and more exciting and more and
more capable
and uh yeah i'm hoping that you're gonna
leave one of us maybe i'll
we could fight over which one later but
i'll take the 15 you take the 17.
yeah i think i'm just going to take this
one right with me you know he takes it
it'll be the thing
here's the thing i think we're friends
then he doesn't trust us at all that's
what happens
maybe next time i thought you wanted
people to come in and take the products
home you know
what happened
we really are grateful to have andy here
to be able to
comment on these products he is an
ultimate expert after all
and we are also grateful to once again
get to spoil the audience
or at least one person because it's time
for another giveaway let's do it let's
jump into it here another razor store
giveaway as a reminder to enter this
you're gonna go to razor.com slash razor
store slash
live and enter you can also enter by
posting your battle station on instagram
you're going to want to tag razer and
hashtag razor ces
2021 in order to get enter now that's
going to enter you
in the giveaways all day long and
speaking of that i think we're getting
ready to
take a look here and it's going to be
the tomahawk now i'm particularly
excited about this because you have a
tomahawk mini itx and the tomahawk atx
mid tower that we talked about
at razercon 2020 and for this giveaway
gabby the winner could choose if they
want the mini itx or the atx
i don't know if i have ever heard of
choice when it comes to
a giveaway so that is just an extra
level of prestige that somebody is going
to get today
before we find out who the winner is we
do want to take a look at some of those
battle stations you have all been
submitting we got to see three amazing
ones earlier
and the next one to come to you is from
ice ice baby
look at that cap shield on the left oh
that is sweet look at that yeah i was
going to say that's a
dope captain america shield they're lit
up with all the chroma as well great
looking set up ice baby thank you for
sending along your battle station
congrats to you for getting that because
mine arrived scratched when i got my
shield
i love the reflection there i'm also
loving the fact that we are continuing
to see these cool colors you can even
get a
bit of a vibe of their taste based on
what's on their screens a little bit of
synthwave colors coming in from percival
i dig it for sure
yeah i'll dig it i dig it gosh these
make me so jealous
i love so xenomorpho has hit us
with the classic razor green i'll just
say i know you're
you traditionally write a classic razor
green look yeah you dig it that's one of
the things that actually drew me to the
brand before even learning about the rgb
and everything i thought ha ha
well the main lit color is one that i
enjoyed and then found out that you
could customize more and think okay
that's really cool but these are these
battle stations
only one winner though and the person
that has their choice of prize is
brianna moore
from canada congratulations he just got
a major upgrade
brandon moore congrats racer team will
be reaching out to you to make sure that
you go ahead and get to choose between
your mini itx and atx to be honest
it's going to probably depend on your
setup your space your desk everything
like that but
you have an option between the tomahawk
mini itx or midtower atx and they will
be reaching out to you
but don't worry everyone we've got a lot
of giveaways so far that that's been
what a
us winner and a canon winner so north
america dominated so far
but uh knowing how many people we have
watching from around the world i'm sure
we're going to see a few winners pop up
from different regions as well so make
sure you get your giveaways your entries
in excuse me for the giveaways because
we have several more before the show's
over and a big big
big one at the end if you haven't heard
of it just yet and
on that note we have another big big
announcement introducing to you our next
partnership
let's check it out
hi everyone my name is craig i'm the
chief business officer at roblox
i'm very excited to talk with you all
about our new partnership with razer
but before i do and for those of you
that aren't familiar with roblox
we're a global platform where tens of
millions of people gather every day
to share experiences with their friends
in millions of immersive 3d worlds
players can build the ultimate theme
park they can be a professional race car
driver
they can star in a fashion show become a
superhero
or just design a dream home to hang out
in with their friends
the diversity of the experiences comes
from the fact
that every single world on roblox is
built by someone in the roblox community
which is made up of millions of creators
roblox is free to download and free to
play on all modern smartphones
tablets computers as well as the xbox
one oculus rift in htc vive
but back to the task at hand we are very
excited to announce our new partnership
with razer
both roblox and razer have large and
incredibly avid fan bases
as of last july roadblocks had over 165
million
monthly active users and we know that
razer products are the brand of choice
for gamers all over the world
it's super exciting to bring these two
brands together
roblox users will now be able to play on
roblox with their favorite razer mice
keyboards and headsets with special
roblox designs
they can also use them to build
immersive worlds and design
cool avatars on roblox down the road
for these creators we're also talking
with razer about enabling these creators
to design custom print on-demand
products for their fans
we're so excited to work with razer and
we can't wait to see how everyone enjoys
these great products
thank you
bet you didn't know we were going to hit
you with roblox today yeah
i was going to say great to hear from
the roblox team as well i mean when you
talk about things that are taking over
the world i think razer and roblox are
in that category
uh you heard about uh the the player
account i mean the amount of experiences
that are coming out
of roblox of course but not just that
but the amount of content that's being
consumed across
uh twitch youtube facebook everywhere
it's absolutely incredible and it's once
again another example
of two powerhouse brands coming together
and i think fans of razer fans of roblox
are gonna be really excited
yeah i mean when i think about the
overall goal at razer to really increase
the immersion when it comes to your
gaming experience a lot of that
takes that partnership with these other
groups to be able to make that fully
possible
and make sure that you're hitting on the
needs and desires of both
audiences so i'm very excited to see
what comes of this spring 2021 is when
you'll be getting more details on the
products
and remember we do want to hear in real
time what you think of what you're
seeing on the screen
what partnerships you might desire to
have for razer in the future
so let us know in whatever chat you're
hanging out in absolutely let us know
especially also what you're hoping to
see from razer and roblox together
whether it be hardware related or
whether it be
in-game related as well lots to look
forward to definitely in terms of razer
and roblox together
i just keep getting these spikes of
energy as we do a new thing each time
and we're about to do another really
cool bravo yeah we're just getting into
it
but uh we have a special guest we teased
a bit
earlier i don't know if anyone has
really gotten the guesses right yet yeah
we'll go ahead and give everyone just a
few seconds to get your guesses in terms
of who you think our special guest is
for today's show
and as a hint as they start to roll in
we'll go ahead and say they also
performed at the razercon 2020 after
party as well which might help you out
is that enough of a hint do you all have
it in your brain did you type it in the
twitch chat already i hope so
because it is time to introduce to you
our special guest for the day
known both in the gaming and music
community as dead mouse we are
so excited to be able to get to hear
from him
directly here on the ces 2021 edition of
razer store live bravo i am
so ready to be bringing him into our
show and the action right now there we
go dead mouse
welcome to the show hi how you guys
doing
hey we're doing great man it's great to
have you here of course gabby and i both
fans of your work we know so many people
part of the razer community
fans of your work as well and we'll get
right into it in terms of razer
and dead mouse or something that we got
to announce right off the top in terms
of razer customs
nice who's who's taking care of that you
guys are me let's see uh
up to you we wanted to let you have the
honors otherwise we could speak to it
too let us know
oh we got we got mouse pads whoa
yeah let's go ahead and get them on the
screen here not only do we have mouse
pads but we also have the architect pro
shocker so excited to see these i think
people who
are looking to upgrade their setups and
of course their phone case as well are
going to be excited as you see
architect pro as well as the gigantis
coming here now gigantis v2
all moused out which is exciting to see
uh gabby do you know when we combine
these items deadness do you know when
and where people can get these i got to
assume it's going to be at razer.com
i i would imagine i think it's on their
site thing right
their webshop i think it's got to be
yeah and i'm sure people that are fans
of both razer and
you and yourself are going to be
extremely excited about this
collaboration bringing the arctic pro
and the gigantic v2 with your whole
branding around it but deadmau5 while we
have you here
i wanted to know you've been making a
lot of exciting moves within the tech
space so generally speaking what have
you been up to
oh man well like a a bunch of stuff
actually one being um a streaming
delivery platform i've partnered up with
some stream
of mine uh i was introduced to a couple
friends from
uh voodoo streamvoodoo.com which is uh
kind of a
video delivery system that came from the
frustrations that i've had with
some other streaming providers and stuff
where it's like well we've got all this
bandwidth we've got all this great stuff
why isn't the quality just not quite
there yet
uh so
yeah that's one thing um the other thing
is i've really been tooling around with
game
quote big big air quotes game
development in unreal 4.
so i've been working on a lot of new
like kind of
i want to say virtual concert but that's
that's kind of been
said to death in 2020 2021 and will be
uh for the next little while but there's
some something along that lines sure
yeah and then is that
oberhassey that you're speaking to there
because we i know a lot of people in the
community are going to be familiar with
the code name over housing stuff that
you started to kind of tease a little
bit
yeah yeah and i i don't know like that
might actually
end up being the ship name who knows
like i like the ring of it
uh but yes over hostly being this just
kind of
uh best way i can explain it is kind of
this environment
that myself and a few other artists have
been working on and uh some in-game
mechanics kind of thing
to be able to do um
for lack of a better term let's just say
concerts in unreal
uh that are going to be delivered as a
client so that people can then
explore environments and listen to music
and watch performances
sure i think a lot of people have seen
maybe just a few of the teases where you
have kind of things rigged up just a
little bit which
which i know i'm personally excited
about as well uh but along those same
lines you've also got osc pilot which a
lot of people have tracked since last
year as well
um which is another cool thing
especially i imagine in these
tricky times where digital artists are
kind of having to get creative i think
uh be awesome for people who haven't
heard about osce pilot just what it
offers uh artists
um it's basically a control surface
software where that can be run on either
any
any touch screen enabled device
and we've got mac os coming out for it
soon and all that stuff so it'll be
on your ipad your phone your mac or your
razer or whatever whatever you want um
and it's kind of a niche
software that kind of came out of
necessity for myself and my shows and
stuff and now we've just kind of
this year and last year have polished it
up to make it
deliverable and easy to use for everyone
cool now on your you mentioned earlier
uh stream voodoo
and i just wanted to go back to that for
a second because you actually have the
title supreme
overlord when it comes to looking this
up so
what does that actually mean as far as
the explicit role you play within this
platform
um kind of their i know how to push
things
to very high stress limits in terms of
quality and quantity and stuff so the
partnership kind of came out of like uh
i'd be a good test case scenario for
something like this because i'm
constantly um using this kind of
technology
and i i also know a lot of the tech
under the hood as well so i can offer
some
advice about uh you know implementation
of certain features and uh functions and
stuff like that
awesome i think across all those
projects that we just mentioned uh
people certainly looking forward to
seeing what we see
uh out of each of them um shifting gears
a bit into games any games you
specifically
been playing over over holidays or in
quarantine
yeah roblox no um
dead cells i i don't i i've been
sleeping on it
i love it it's it's my new airplane game
you know when you're traveling
if you're home you can play it on the
switch you can play it on the pc
uh it's great it's it's it's kind of
at the first little bit it feels kind of
repetitive but now
i've got the like the diablo bug about
it where it's like just about you know
improving your time and collecting new
items
it's a solo play game but it's it's like
one of my one of my jams right now i'm
kind of digging it
awesome yeah i think a lot of people
have been sleeping on it yeah it's such
a good feeling when there's a game
you've been sleeping on
right and then you just discover and you
think i've been missing out this whole
time
it's like castlevania yeah yeah yes
so yeah now i know the thing is we just
talked about all of this stuff that
you're
doing you are extremely busy but on top
of that we've heard you're working on a
new album can you tell us more about
that
i've been i've been working on an album
yeah according to interviews for like
the last like what four years
yeah it's it's just it's it's been a
very long slow and arduous process sure
i'm working on at home i think that's an
appropriate question for basically
any any any artist makes music or anyone
you could always just throw that one at
them that's t-ball
that's what we call that so you're
working on an album no actually i've
decided not to do albums anymore
yeah i'm done that's it it's singles and
eps from here on you're right we gotta
talk to our sources
you're right we gotta check it out i
mean as a creative mind right you're
just always getting the wheels turning
and deadmau5 it's been so lovely to be
able to get to speak to you directly
here today are there any last words or
things you'd like to share with the
audience before we let you go
uh no just you know you be sound be safe
and uh have fun being creative with all
this new emerging tech really i mean
also you know using this opportunity um
to
learn new things with this uh new
emerging technology like these new
3080s that are coming out in the new
razer notebooks i think that's going to
be my first thing is getting ue on there
just to
use those as benchmarks and testers and
stuff like that so
while games are fun and great and all
that stuff this technology is like
really something that shouldn't be
overlooked in terms of exploring
development as an innovator in both
the technological and artistic sense we
really do appreciate getting your
insight here today thanks for stopping
by dead mouse
well thanks for having me bye guys see
you nice see you later
we got so much good stuff out of this
interview and also i want to reiterate
on
the products that we talked about
earlier yeah i was going to say i think
before
we end this segment of course it was
great to have dead mouse homie thank you
for joining the show but before we
end this entire segment i think we
should give away some of the razer
customs here on the show
yeah so we talked about this earlier you
know the arctic pro you can see the
design on your screen right now so if
you are a fan of dead mouse and razer
this is exactly for you the gigantic
v2 as well available now looking so
fresh so clean
so in line with all the colors that we
know and love
and if anyone has not been aware of how
to enter
these giveaways make sure that you learn
right now because i'm going to tell you
it's razer.com razorstor live where you
end up signing up
and you can also share your battle
stations with us on instagram tagging
razer and using hashtag razer ces 2021
yeah we had some great giveaways so far
and uh now we're going to go ahead and
see exactly who
might win this gigantic v2 as well
as the architect pro well it's right
there on your screen your last look at
it
as we gear up to not just announce a
winner but also visit some of the battle
stations because we know that you all
are eagerly sharing those across the
board also i encourage people that are
watching go check out the hashtag see
what other battle stations are there too
steve zuniga
right here showing us that again kind of
that verticality with having
the you know right on top of each other
here but i love
seeing the raptor right and its full
glory also hunts for mini there you just
see how much desk space
it frees up i'm lucky to have one of
those at home uh pretty sweet look at
that setup though nice and clean one of
the cleanest we've seen so far
so fresh so clean squishy spongy
panda going for a more subdued look
and wait am i counting am i seeing baby
yoda's there i think i'm actually seeing
two baby yodas with the lighting i'm
like squinting and leaning forward
there's at least two baby yoda's in this
shot which is a first for razer store
live uh but it's a fantastic setup once
again
and battle station from squishy spongy
panda yeah i love the nuance here
and qriksi core this is exactly what we
were talking about before i have a
friend
just like this that completely decks out
their system with all the quartz
addiction
and it looks so weird talking about
clean with our first century but this is
also another level of clean when you got
that unity across the board
absolutely i think we also have a
frappuccino appearance there but not
just that also
crack and kitty up in that upper left
corner so the first kitty appearance of
the day as well the kitty ears on that
kraken but a great setup from quick c
core as well maybe they gain or lose
points depending on the flavor of that
beverage but there's only going to be
one winner of
this giveaway and it is carson mueller
from
germany congratulations we have
officially hit the global territory when
it comes to the giveaway
winners here today you will be enjoying
the new products that we were just
talking about deadmau5 clad
across your mat yes indeed and uh carson
we're going to have the razor team reach
out to you they'll be getting you all
those goodies but once again
and then you've heard it before you're
going to hear it again but we know how
important giveaways are to all of you
tuning in from home and we've got more
giveaways still to come
including that raptor 27 plus full
peripheral set
which is a whole bunch of stuff that i
wish you and i were taking home we won't
be one of you will be but
gabby i do believe that gets us into
what i would call
really the core of this show it's time
to really get into full ces mode
oh yeah new new new we have
all known razer to be at the forefront
of innovation
and this is the ces 2021 edition of the
show
for a reason it's a moment we have all
been waiting for i'm amped up i hope you
are too let's get into it
[Music]
when the covered 19 pandemic first hit
there was a massive global shortage of
medical grade masks
to meet the urgent needs during this
emergency raiser quickly responded by
manufacturing high quality
certified medical grade masks for the
front line workers
today we have donated more than one
million marks globally
but now that we're well and truly
settled into this new normal
we see the need for face masks that is
safe
social and sustainable introducing
project hazel the world's smartest
mask
for safety the mast is classified as
surgical n95 respirator
which provides a high fluid resistance
that protects against droplets
and splashes its active ventilation
brings in cool air and releases heat
produced from exhaling
which also prevents a buildup of co2 in
the mask
aside from safety we also looked how we
could improve
social interaction with the mask as most
designs cover the face
and muffle your speech our smart mask
has a clear transparent design
which makes communicating easier as
others can now see you speak
and pick up your facial cues thanks to a
built-in mic and amplifier combo
our patent-pending voice amp technology
ensures your speech
isn't muffled even when you're masked up
the mask is waterproof and scratch
resistant
making it ideal for frequent use and
because it's made of recyclable plastic
this sustainable design greatly
minimizes wastage
as compared to disposable masks a smart
mask should also be super comfortable to
wear
the silicon guard sits snugly around
your face to prevent air leaking in
and keeps the mask itself from touching
or resting on your mouth so you can talk
naturally
by designing this mask to be safe social
sustainable comfortable and personalized
project hazel is our answer to what the
world's smartest mars can be
bravo i've been practicing my vanna
white skills for this
very moment are you ready i say we do it
ready three two
one go voila this
is the official reveal of the concept
for the world's
smartest mask and i am so excited to
dive into the specifics of this but
before we do
i think we need to go over some of the
reasoning that led
to this very moment because in the video
itself you already heard them talking
directly about the impacts that they've
made through mass production yeah you
might have seen it at razercon actually
as soon as the the pandemic started to
hit uh in
all across the world production
factories razer started producing
mass for frontline workers and actually
the razer community was a big part of
that and actually
making sure that over 1 million masks
were delivered to frontline users so you
and i got a chance to talk to some of
the razer product team about this mask
and really asking what's the next step
that razer can do and here's your first
concept
unveil at ces 2021 it's going to be the
world's smartest mask
and it's exploration here of some really
innovative technology let's talk about
the pillars
of project hazel as you can see on your
screen being
safe social sustainable comfortable and
personalized are at the forefront of the
design of this concept
and first things first talking about the
safety because that is the priority when
it comes to wearing a mask right keeping
yourself safe and you need to make sure
that you have those specific cord
or considerations rather like for
instance it is a surgical n95
respirator not something that's just
slapped on there it's something that you
can rely upon
yeah absolutely i think other cool two
things that one of them you saw from the
video is going to be the act of
ventilation
so that's going to be cool air in and
hot air out which is going to be
fantastic i mean right now
in north america or in the winter and
even in vegas the nights have been
freezing so it's not too bad but i tell
you what in the heat of the summer
especially for
all the all the local folks here in
vegas i know that when it's 112 outside
something like active ventilation in a
mask would be really welcome but also
active sterilization in the mask as well
uh it's pretty fantastic so that covers
kind of safety like you said that's
going to be paramount for this type of
mass but
i think one of the things that you and i
are most excited about and we talked to
the project hazel team this week about
are the social aspects because let's to
to get real for a second it it has kind
of sucked for 10 months 10 plus months
we can't see people smile we can't see
the kind of
the way their excitement in their face
we've only seen half of
everyone's face for the past uh 11
months and it's it has really been
i think it's taken a lot of toll on
people so the social aspects of the mask
are really cool
i've been trying to force myself to be
more of an eyebrow communicator
when we're wearing these masks and it's
just not easy so
that was one of the things i immediately
noticed was just the clear overall
plastic capping here so that
you can actually see what people look
like
under it without sacrificing any of the
safety
and then also thinking about the fact
how many times have you tried to talk to
someone through
a mask you know at a safe distance and
you're trying to push and strain your
voice over that
well you have voice amp technology from
razer in here too so you can
have comfort knowing that you're
speaking at your normal volume and it's
getting communicated effectively to
whoever you do
i have been yelling through the masks
the whole show and then
and the whole time in prep for this and
i think that's one thing another cool
thing though is certainly that low light
mode if you think about just being able
to
actually turn on so if you're in a
scenario where it is dark or anything
like that you're actually going to be
able to
see the low light mode kind of lighting
up and being able to give you
that so i think it's pretty fantastic if
you see the lights coming on just a bit
there in the map probably hard to tell
in this light just because of course we
are daytime here in vegas but
you got actually light kind of that just
illuminates the face just a little bit
which is another great social aspect but
that brings us into
all the sustainable features of the mask
as well yeah i mean i love the low light
right because you don't want it blasting
your face you want it to be a
nice and lit and when it comes to that
sustainability we're talking about how
many masks have been donated and things
of the sort but
even how many are used right i think the
latest that we heard from the razer team
was over three million
single-use mass disposed every single
day which first of all great
that everyone is as masking up but the
toll that that's taking on the
environment
uh is is pretty substantial yeah so
you've got to think
how do you get around that how do you
try and make an improvement in that
aspect in our footprint that we're
making on the earth and well replaceable
filters having the rechargeable
ventilators these are all aspects that
are going to allow you to be using these
and then the duration itself is actually
applicable
for daily use so it's not like yeah i
went on my dog walk for an hour and then
now i got to go home and charge this
thing up and what am i really going to
do at this point you have that
opportunity
to really enjoy that sustainability
wireless charging case with the usb
stylizer by the way if you didn't know
the case is so great too just the way
that that works
right now these prototypes of course
this easy charge cable and you're able
to kind of set everything up so i think
the sustainability of the mask is
incredible but also something that is
super important and
it's hard to say which of these is the
most important but this one's up there
uh
just comfort and how this mask sits i
think there's a few things that have to
do with that the first of that's going
to be of course adjustable ear loops
and customizable sizes that they're
thinking about but also not just that
but the
the silicone around the mask i think
that's an important one because
with a lot of these masks you do have
kind of like openings and then areas for
droplets to get in and things like that
as we settle into this new normal a mass
that is comfortable
and as safe as it can be is definitely
going to be important yeah and as
somebody i know i'm not alone there's
got to be somebody
watching that also experiences this that
has really sensitive skin
having something completely across the
whole way can be difficult but silicone
on the other hand i mean i haven't had
any issues ever when putting that on my
face so
having something that can still seal
effectively while having that airflow
available so you don't feel suffocated
within it is really
really cool you know what's also super
cool i was going to say there's one more
thing we got to talk about with this map
very razor-esque i'm going to let you
have the honors gabby all right i
am ready y'all ready so you know we
showed you low-light we got
our actual chroma rgb on the outside
as well so if you do want to look extra
fancy
you definitely can and that's the
greatest thing right i just want to look
cool
i want to look cool while i'm doing the
things uh yeah of course
it would not be a razor concept without
some chroma integration you could see it
right there
um and i think this as you mentioned
gabby not just the way that
of course this being a concept those who
might just be jumping in to check out
this mask reveal
one of the concepts coming out from
razer this year at ces but
uh one of the coolest things about these
two is the way that the case charge and
the ways that
these prototypes charge as well it's
just so easy and i think
uh of all the things that you know we
need from a technological perspective um
this is a pretty exciting one and i'm
you know i got my fingers crossed that
we might see some more from project
hazel in the future
from razer because i'm so excited about
this but we did have a social campaign
you might have seen on twitter
all the razer social channels that kind
of lit up and said we want you to guess
what this year is
this year's ces is about one of the
product unveils and uh so a lot of
people they went to photoshop they
inverted the image they kind of cheated
they saw that it was a mask so many of
you guessed that it was a mask and
that's exactly what project hazel is but
we're gonna go ahead and announce that
winner now of that social giveaway
somebody guessed it right somebody is
winning a set of peripherals and that
somebody is stelian lenga from romania
congratulations your guessing skills
were on par
which means you get rewarded to boot
with those peripherals we're just giving
away so much love today
we really are and i got to say a huge
shout out to the whole razer team and
everyone working on project hazel
because it's so cool to get these
prototypes just got here just before
the show just in time for ces and it's
really exciting to be able to to hear
from them on something that
you know the world really desperately
needs innovation in because i think
we're getting tired of the current mass
we're wearing and i think the new normal
has been the new normal for a little bit
too long so i am personally really
excited well that's one of the biggest
things right i think when
wearing the masks people realizing just
how this is the new
normal so if it's something that you're
going to be doing on the daily you might
as well be doing it in the most
effective and stylish way possible
i love the fact that every time we step
into the store we get to learn about
something new whether it's
project hail hazel with the concept of
the world's smartest mask
or the last time we were here and we got
to learn about the isker because that
was the first official move into the
gaming chair space always bringing
something new to us
absolutely i think it was cool to see
that it was also cool to talk to the
razer
esker team leads as well talking about
the innovation that they did in terms of
lumbar support that they looked at
competitor gaming chairs what they were
offering what they weren't offering
but the cool news is that here as far as
our second concept announcement we've
got more in store there so let's go
ahead
and check it out
[Music]
[Music]
so when it comes to these concepts and i
come home and i'm in my safe space
and i have taken off my project hazel
mask project brooklyn shared that's what
i want to sit in
absolutely i mean this is amazing this
here as you see transform into next gen
immersion
with project brooklyn a concept gaming
chair from razer at ces
2021 you go from a full chair all the
way into
an immersive gaming station and uh just
take a look here on your screen you can
see exactly how everything morphs out
you saw in the video but you can also
take a look here
gabby i know you and i both just love
the form factor of how this thing
transforms
into that immersive gaming station yeah
you just saw in the video as well as on
your screen kind of the intricacies of
this actual design all the way on the
left the starting positioning of this
chair
looking much more like something that
would take your average amount of space
for a chair
and then folding out all the way into
what you see on the right which includes
that deployable
60 inch full surround oled display
which will not only optimize your actual
immersive experience
by having that in a surrounding
situation but think about the fact that
it's not going to be taking a huge
footprint
in your house right a lot of times when
you think of these major setups you're
like all right
do i got to get a new apartment maybe
i'll upgrade to a house i got to put a
whole room in it but now
you're going to get everything like that
in this much more compact design
including the things you know and love
like the modular 4d armrest for the
customizability for your level of
comfort certainly and also that's going
to give you the option as you see maybe
you're gaming on controller maybe you're
gaming on your switch maybe you're
gaming on a mouse and keyboard all
that's possible as you saw during that
video as well
another thing to talk about is just kind
of the ergonomics of the entire chair
that's going to come in the form of the
hypersense technology
which is going to be the the actual
tactile feedback in the chair powered by
razer hypersense and then also the
carbon fiber bucket seat so you're going
to have a really comfortable feel there
for ergonomics and then
how can we forget it of course powered
by razer chroma rgb
through and through you saw a little bit
in the concept video but in terms of the
chair itself and that low
floor lighting as well this concept
powered by chroma as well
this is what just makes me think about
how so much of immersion is just hitting
on to the different senses so when you
think about that hypersense technology
and getting that sort of feedback but as
well as the visuals
that are available through the caroma
rgb system that we have been able to
enjoy through multiple razor products
and being here in this project brooklyn
concept
i love the fact that i could think about
putting this in my living room to be
able to
sit and enjoy some console gaming and
then i can take out
the actual tray to put my keyboard on if
i do want to make it a pc extruder
even as you saw in that kind of first
example just using it as a standard desk
chair as a gaming chair and then when
you want to actually
game pull it back just a little bit i
mean if you think about anyone who does
own a display that is something like
a 50 plus curved monitor you know how
much space that takes up you generally
need to get a desk that can fit that so
the idea that all of this would be built
into one is is pretty incredible so i
got to say project brooklyn another
thing that we're really excited about
and uh
that's your second concept from ces that
uh and our
item two of two that we really hope we
get to see more of from razer gonna
cross our fingers
it's just so crazy to me in the best way
possible thinking about the fact that it
was just last year we learned about the
isker being the first
gaming chair for them and the reason i
keep mentioning that is they went from
that
to this concept you just saw before you
so razer always having that idea of
we're trying to make sure you get the
best immersive experience possible
while not limiting ourselves to what is
actually
available for us to develop in
technology ces is all about looking
towards the future after all it really
is and we got to give a huge shout out
to the razer teams because uh just how
you know how much work went into both of
these uh projects so far
like you and i had got the opportunity
to have a few phone calls with them this
week and
it's so especially when you look at
something like hazel as well that has
been brought together so quickly the
fact they were able to get prototypes
out to us for ces to have in hand
really special as well and can't wait to
see what we see from brooklyn as well
and let us know in chat which uh which
one
you're excited about you're probably
excited about both but let us know what
your thoughts are
on the concept so far uh because it's
been really special a set of unveils
concepts the ultimate epitome of what it
is here at ces
the thing is bravo this is where i get
to the bittersweet point
we've revealed all of these
announcements from products to
partnerships to the concepts themselves
and it's time for us to reflect upon all
of it and digest what we learned and to
do that
we got to bring our buddy back in we got
andy schaefer
the manager here at razer store las
vegas joining us once
more no more more vape though you've
toned it down yeah just more
yeah you know okay because it's casual
yeah this is your
relaxed wind down from the show exactly
you know we started off with
up here we're gonna bring it down bring
it down keep it going keep the flow
so on that note though you've gotten to
sit back whether you're with here with
us or
on the side of reflect upon everything
that we've seen today
generally speaking what was your
favorite moment of today uh you know
there's so many different things whether
it was the new blade announcements or
product hazel project brooklyn hazel and
brooklyn hot off the presses i mean
this is something i mean we only heard
it like past few weeks when we started
to get involved with razer
for this show we started to hear about
it but i know for you as well it's kind
of all just come together so quick and
it's been amazing it has it has and i
just think that you know we've talked
about it earlier with the systems and
everything else
just really taking it to the next level
and that's what hazel and brooklyn do
without a doubt
absolutely they were they were kept
under wraps the code names the projects
they were they
were they were under tight wraps for ces
i mean but some people might have missed
earlier when they're watching the show
we also did get to talk and reveal some
hardware i mean the blade 15 as well as
blade 17 pro that we came through
we got some of your expert opinion on
that as well too
yeah you know and it's just you know we
focused on the
rtx 30 series cars we talk about the
fastest displays
the lightweight the portability
everything about them is just
awesome and amazing absolutely and
partnership announcements were great too
in terms of cenrio
baldur's gate as well as roblox i think
people are going to look forward to more
and more of those and as
razer continues to take over the world
and teaming up with other brands that
are taking over the world it's exciting
to see those emerge
even though it's all obviously very
exciting to us i'm curious andy what is
your
favorite thing is it a partnership
reveal
or is it a new hardware reveal in terms
of just seeing kind of the audience
getting jacked up about it
uh you know i think store specific
i love the new hardware because it's
something that we can touch and play
with and all that sort of stuff i think
overall it's all the great partnerships
and everything
uh if you have to ask me personally it's
definitely i would say the hardware just
it actually gives us something cool you
know something else great to really
share with the fans that walk in every
day something that's cool too is when we
get ready for these razor
shows here being our second show able to
do here it's amazing to see people walk
by on the street and then they
oh so many people double take you're
here every day so i'm sure you see
people are walking down not expecting to
see a store like this right and then
they do a double take and then they pop
in we also learned that they also take
pictures of the very small las vegas
sign which
is the real one it's been amazing to see
people kind of just like
they do a double take and then they come
right in the store because like i got to
see what's in here most definitely
yeah getting to hear from dead mouse
earlier was also great very cool
sending someone home with those products
but it is ces
it is a special edition which means we
got some special something something
going on too
yeah so you know we've got that special
promotion that's going to run from today
through the 17th it's going to be that
20
off your second item uh anything either
on razorstore.com or
in our stores 20 off that is nothing to
scoff
at my friends and you may have caught it
earlier in the show when i was talking
about kind of holding off on my purchase
just for that but there are other
specifics too when it comes to store
orders
yeah so you know you get your second
item and you know what we're going to
get to you really quick next day
business shipping
14 days risk free return policy so
whether it's in-store or online and you
can extend your warranty up to three
years with razor care
so complete peace of mind all the way
through
excellent i love it i love it well andy
it's been so wonderful getting to chat
with you thank you thank you guys thanks
for bringing me back again yeah any last
words for the razer community
you are one of the people that they get
to interact with when they come into the
store
that was kind of blowing up about you
wearing your baby gear yeah the people
who didn't cop were a little
to your fans out there what you got to
say well no i just say you know thank
you everybody for coming in continuing
to stay safe i think that's one of the
biggest things thank you guys for
continuing to bring awareness of razor
stores and everything else and i'm just
so excited about all the new products
stuff that we've unveiled here for ces
and just
excited to always see what's next so
yeah
i hope we're back here with you soon for
another razor store live yeah yeah
hopefully
thanks for having us thanks guys until
then andy will let you
shuffle off and enjoy the last moments
of the show i think uh gabby we got
probably one more pretty big thing to
cover before we close today's show don't
you think so wasn't there something
pretty big we were teasing
i think so it is our final giveaway of
the day and we got to save the best for
last because it is quite a good one
everybody this is going to be a raptor
with full suite of peripherals
right there on your screen we actually
got to see the raptor 27 in some of the
setups from the battle stations earlier
i absolutely love the raptor 27 i'm a
big fan of the 27 inch form factor a lot
of people kind of
you know coming from 22 23-inch monitors
into that 27-day just a little bit
better of a setup whether it's for
productivity or for gaming of course for
both but there's so much more here too
gabby
in this full giveaway let's talk about
the entire grand prize if you're
thinking that you need a little bit of
an upgrade to your keyboard razer
huntsman elite has gotten you covered
also the mouse experience with the razer
viper ultimate
as well as the razer goliath the the
goliath this
extended chroma extend it's always my
preference by the way so you're very
lucky for getting this one
and then the razer black shark v2 pro we
talk a lot about these products and how
having all your bases covered from your
mouse experience to the keyboard to your
mat to your audio and having that all
connected in a way
isn't just great from a visual
standpoint and having that continuation
of the chroma rgb
but just from an experience an immersion
standpoint yeah we talk about of course
when we're looking at these
battlestations we talk about the chroma
we talk about everything together but of
course these are just
a set of really badass products that
anyone is going to be lucky to have and
i know so many of you have been entering
all day in an effort to try to win but
before we announce that grand prize
winner
as is now become tradition we want to
take a look at our few of our favorites
throughout the day a logical clown
hitting us with
nothing but supreme logic with itself
right here
they've got a really nice background
going too but pretty much everything
they could possibly need here in the
setup
we'll stay home game on appreciate it
staying safe let's go ahead and check
out the next set up a logical clown
thank you for sending in but here's
kinches
and look at this setup as we take a look
some great chroma going on even a little
bit of a laptop stand action but
i'm pretty sure that's like a hue strip
under lighting there from the chroma on
the long board which is pretty sweet as
well i think that is a
razor store live first as well yeah
that's not thinking i mean we talked
about how you can just replace your
desktop with one of the blades as well
so it's really cool to actually see that
in
action as the proven aspect and the
lighting to boot to keep it all across
the board
really contrasted by noah try
and ski who i love it they've got it
kind of like the traditional two
monitor setup but really also maybe the
first nikki's deck
we've seen on the show right he's nike
stack just front and center and a
i'm glad we got to see at least a little
snacky stack appearance in
these setups here looking front and
center thank you for helping us plant
some trees with conservation
international but
that does it for our battle station
previews now all of these people already
got their battle station set up but the
winner of the full set
is going to be dalia campa from the
united states congratulations
you will be going home with a raptor and
full suite of peripherals
meaning next time we got giveaways going
on we expect you to be sharing your
battle station with us
you now have an obligation to in the
next razor store live you're going to
need to make sure that you
show us how you've built this setup out
because it is an amazing setup
indeed i'm not gonna lie i'm pretty
jealous about you taking home that grand
prize
but we know you're gonna enjoy that
entire suite of razor goodies and uh
if you didn't grab a giveaway today
don't worry just make sure you stay
tuned to razer social channels and
you'll get
informed of the next razor store live
which gabby actually is coming up just
around the corner in less than a month
yeah what do you know we weren't lying
when we were saying this was a monthly
ordeal february 2nd
is when the next razor store live event
is expected to
go down that's right around the corner
oh my goodness
it absolutely is and i think it's been
so fantastic there's no no one across
hardware that's doing something like a
monthly show for their community where
you get to hear from product teams
things like that so
uh really looking forward to that next
episode as well yeah and anybody who has
been returning for each of these shows
we appreciate your continued support
and being in the community we love being
able to go and look at the chats of
everybody that has been
involved of course in this time between
shows make sure you're going to the
razor store you know the website
checking out the products seeing exactly
what you want to be interacting with but
bravo that does it for everything that
we have to share
final reflection upon the day what
thoughts do you have oh man i think the
first thing i want to thank of course is
everyone joining us from home
watching here whether whatever platform
you're tuning in from of course these
shows are community shows these are for
you guys and we're excited to see
uh you every each time where you're
tuning in from things like that it's
great to have you as part of these shows
and to be honest you are the life of
these shows we
just get to talk about exciting razer
products but also a big shout out of
course gabby also
to the razer teams the product teams
that we got to talk to who are working
hard on
delivering some awesome stuff but uh
yeah i want to thank everyone who's been
involved and also i want to thank you
it was great to be back here uh with you
at the razer store and i hope we can
get together for more of these because
they're a special show yeah well thank
you bravo for being by my side and
hanging with me for the entirety of this
razor
store live it has been an amazing
experience and
a special thank you to as you said all
of the members of the razer team
there are so many that we got to speak
to that you didn't even see on the show
that contributed to
making this possible so much
appreciation but
on behalf of myself the entire
production crew
and the razer team we are so grateful
that you were tuning in here today until
next time we hope that you stay safe
healthy and
game on everyone good morning afternoon
evening
and good night
you